the cdc is updating its mass guidance
for schools now advising quote
universal indoor masking for all
teachers staff and students
regardless of vaccination status end
quote
but some school districts are opting to
leave the masking decision
up to parents joining us now is justin
davis he's a member of the gaston county
school board in north carolina
and brian gregan whose two kids are
enrolled in
king george county schools in virginia
so i'm going to start with you justin
your board voted unanimously to let
parents have that option of course this
was
prior to the cdc's new recommendations
on masking in school do you expect that
decision to stand or do you think that
things will be revised given the cdc's
latest
announcements well i appreciate you
having me on this morning and thank you
um you know i think parents are best
suited to make decisions for what's
right for their child
and the cdc of course is a national
organization
and has given that guidance but you know
i don't necessarily believe that we need
a one-size-fits-all policy for everyone
in this country
what's right for the citizens of gaston
county and the students of our county is
not necessarily the same as in san
francisco california or
new york new york and it's okay if we do
things differently in gaston county than
they do elsewhere
right now we have the ability to have
that local control
and uh these are the type of decisions
that i think should remain
uh with local control and i hope that
will continue yeah
that makes sense i mean some southern uh
some
counties down by the border we're seeing
it 900 surgeon
in covet cases um so yeah obviously you
know one size doesn't fit
fit all um let's talk with you now brian
you have how many children
i have two children two children do you
like this decision of leaving it up to
the the parents to decide making masks
wearing optional in schools
yes i think it's the best thing to do
for all parents because as a parent i
would rather be in charge of making
the decisions the health decisions for
my children i don't think the government
has a place in that um it doesn't have a
role in that as far as i'm concerned
and and there's a lot of uh you know
there's a lot of questions
surrounding the efficacy of mask in
general
and i but i don't think that i'm i don't
think that
i think parents should have the option
so if a parent wants their child to wear
a mask that's okay
but if they don't want them to wear a
mask that should be okay too and i
should have that
ability to you know if i think that my
children are still safe going to school
without a mask
then that that should be all right you
know brian i must stay with you for a
second because of your two children
i've i get letters all the time i'm a
mother of nine i've seen the impact of
mask wearing for my own kids i've seen
increases in acne germs i got a letter
yesterday from a mom a grandmother
actually saying
her her grandkids have dental problems
because wearing the mask that long
there's some sort of issues that
dentists are now seeing an uptick
in issues um with that so there are oth
and then not to mention anxiety and
other things
um what kind of impact did wearing a
mask um all you know
last year for example have with your
children and what would concern you if
that were to change
um and and and it was not optional for
your children moving forward
well because of the mask mandate of last
school year we did not send our kids
back when we had the option to
and there were other reasons for that
you know my wife stays at home with
brendan you know for for other for other
reasons we we we did it
that way but um but but but yeah i think
that
that if if they do require mass you know
i think
it's best for our children especially my
oldest to be in school
and um you know we would have to just
try to work around it maybe if
the school board would allow for an
exemption for parents who
who think that it's unsafe for their
children to wear a mask you know that
would be appropriate too because
i don't think as mr davis says it's not
a one size fits all
yeah justin brian thank you for joining
us this morning and giving us your
thoughts on that
i'm certainly looking forward to more
smiles and less masks
moving into the school year in the fall
thank you both
thank you rachel